hello I'm Frank the likely ofer miss I'd
like to thank lab roots for this
opportunity to share the work of our
labs today we're going to talk about
characterization of biotherapeutics by
NMR and about the analytical methods and
computational methods that we use to
extract useful information from the
spectra and the work that we're going to
be presenting today has been conducted
at NIST by many collaborators including
the folks in my group
Luke Arbogast Robert Brinson and our
group leader John Moreno postdoc Korth
Wade Eliot and I'm in this main campus
our computational colleagues Ryan Evans
Tony fiercely Felix Perez and
Christopher schenzel and the ITL our
colleagues David Sheen and Vincent Shen
what's our motivation for studying
biotherapeutics well if we look at a
list of the top 10 drugs by sales what
we discover is that seven of these are
biologics that is to say protein drugs
and of those six of them are monoclonal
antibodies what we also call Mavs for
short there's two stories in this table
so one is of course that these protein
based drugs are important life-changing
life-saving therapeutics which is why
they're at the top list here but in
addition they're also incredibly
expensive with some treatments costing
as much as one or $200,000 for a year's
worth of therapy so any analytical and
computational methods that we can bring
to bear to make this important class of
therapeutics more accessible more
affordable more stable easier to develop
those can have impact and so that's what
we're gonna talk about today as a little
digression it's useful to consider what
traditional drug discs
every has been about small molecule drug
discovery like aspirin tylenol and so on
so most small molecule drugs work by
targeting a specific protein or class of
proteins like the one shown on this
slide which is cyclooxygenase or Cox
this protein catalyzes creation of
prostaglandins that promote inflammation
and from our chains that promote blood
clotting so if you can find a small
molecule that will interfere with this
protein you can prevent blood clotting
and prevent inflammation responses and
that's now meds like aspirin work now it
was known for more than two thousand
years that willow bark which contains
salicylic acid was a good way to reduce
fever and inflammation and based on that
understanding over time when people
deduce the structure of salicylic acid
and had the wherewithal to make chemical
modifications drug companies came up
with the modification aspirin and then
later on additional systemic
modifications like acetaminophen and
ibuprofen and so this has been a kind of
paradigm for a small molecule drug
discovery we have buildings full of
synthetic organic chemists making small
chemical changes to common molecular
scaffolds and testing generally by trial
and error whether or not a particular
molecule can bind to the target protein
of interest and in this case with the
cyclooxygenase many different small
molecule drugs have been found to bind
to this protein and make a useful drug
there's a kind of corollary to this
however which is that if you can find
many different small molecules that will
all work to target this particular
protein it also implies that these small
molecules might target other proteins
that you don't really want
targeted in other words when you make a
small molecule drug it will commonly
have side effects and in fact this is
often why drugs fail and the failure
rate is about 90% and in spite of all
the additional information we've brought
to bear about structural biology that
failure rate hasn't changed much so
small molecule drug discovery still
depends on trying large numbers of
compounds against a drug target and a
big pharma company might have compounds
several million compounds in a library
that they can rely on so that small
molecule drug discovery of course
proteins themselves can be used as drugs
this is what we call biologic therapy
attics or biologics and probably the
most well-known and common one is
insulin that regulates glucose levels
and there are other ones that we know
about like Epogen filgrastim that
stimulate production of blood cells so
these are all naturally occurring
proteins that we can manufacture in
cells in living cells extract them and
administer them as drugs now we notice
that there are many monoclonal antibody
drugs in the list of the top ten why is
that what we already considered that in
small molecule drug discovery trying
large numbers of different compounds
against the target is a good way to find
particular compound that will hit your
target of interest in the case of
antibodies these have been designed by
nature to vary in such a way that allows
them to bind to many different targets
very specifically so here's a little
cartoon of what an antibody looks like
it has three domains the little doughnut
shaped domain at the bottom is what we
call the FC domain this part binds to
the immune cell receptor and at the top
are the
two identical fad domains of the
antibody and at the ends of the fad
domains are the places that binds to the
antigen whatever it is that the
monoclonal antibody is targeting now we
talked about the fact that a big drug
company might have five or ten million
compounds in their small molecule
database but an individual human can
make over ten billion different kinds of
antibodies so antibodies are an amazing
source of structural diversity and
bioengineering allows us to select
particular antibodies that will bind
very specifically to pretty much most
any target that we like and so for this
reason and for some others monoclonal
antibodies have been become very
attractive vehicles for drug discovery
recognizing that at NIST where we like
to help the development of measurements
and standards we developed a standard
monoclonal antibody reference that can
be used to develop and validate
technologies for studying therapeutic
proteins like monoclonal antibodies and
we're going to use this reference
antibody called the NIST lab for several
examples in the following slides now in
the case of a small molecule drug like
aspirin it's an organic molecule and we
can specify pretty much everything about
it according to its network of chemical
bonds its covalent structure but the
situation for protein therapeutics is
different than that the covalent
structure what we call the primary
sequence of the protein the amino acid
sequence can be determined very
accurately by techniques like mass
spectroscopy however in order for the
protein drug to function properly it has
to be folded into a very specific
structure and it has to stay in that
structure and not aggregate so in the
case of protein structure or what we may
also call high order structure there's a
hierarchy of organization starting with
the primary sequence the secondary
structure small structural elements like
HeLa C's and sheets the overall fold of
the protein and then finally any
complexes that the protein might form in
order for the protein to be safe and
efficacious it has to be folded properly
and it can't be aggregated because if
it's aggregated even in such a way that
preserves its activity it can present a
different shape to the immune system an
unfamiliar shape that will cause an
immune response the immune response
might make that dosage of the medicine
ineffective or it might threaten the
life of the patient
so important challenge and we have to
address it
the difficulty is as we get higher up
this chain this hierarchy of structure
it becomes more difficult to measure the
details of structure and atom level
resolution so we're gonna try to resort
to the analytical methods of NMR to help
us discover the details about high order
structure now in order to best conserve
the structure and stabilize it from
unfolding and aggregation it's common
for these protein drugs which are
administered by injection to have one or
more excipient added to the injection
solution to keep the protein stable and
uh negra gated and actually deciding
which collection and concentration of
these excipient compounds are in a
particular therapy deck is actually in
important aspect of development so
having analytical techniques to assist
this would also be useful now in the
area of structural biology where we use
NMR it's very well known that the 2d
hydrogen nitrogen correlation spectrum
is closely associated with the
particular structure of a protein and
very indicative of small structural
features for example what you see here
are two NMR spectra of the protein
therapeutic called filgrastim or g-csf
on the right hand side is the NMR
spectrum of the intact protein properly
folded and on the left hand side is a
spectrum of that same molecule but in
its unfolded state so this is a rather
extreme demonstration the little spots
in the spectrum are like mountain peaks
and the position of one of those spots
in the horizontal direction is the NMR
chemical shift the frequency of a
particular amide hydrogen atom of one
amino acid in the protein and that Peaks
position in the vertical axis is the
chemical shift of the corresponding
nitrogen that that hydrogen atom is
bound to so together the hydrogen and
nitrogen are chemically active and they
can be excellent reporters on structural
and environmental changes of the protein
and if you have happen to conduct the
assignment procedure of mapping out
which of these peaks in the spectrum
belongs to which amino acid in the
protein
you cannot changes in the spectra onto
the surface of the protein of interest
and decide as in this case where the
spectrum exhibits exhibits signs of
oxidation of particular methionine we
can see which other parts of the protein
I get manipulated as well so NMR gives
us a way to extract structural
information of proteins and solution
more or less as formulated but we'd like
to apply them to really big molecular
systems like monoclonal antibodies which
are several times larger than the
proteins usually studied by NMR
spectroscopy which is generally limited
by how quickly a molecule can tumble
that is to say more slowly coming
molecules make NMR measurements more
difficult and so while a monoclonal
antibody is very big 150 kill adults and
tumbles very slowly the methyl groups of
side chains in a monoclonal antibody are
reorienting very rapidly so even though
the protein as a whole is tumbling
slowly we can measure spectrum very
effectively without isotopic labeling
for the carbons and protons of methyl
groups in the protein side chains and
about a third of the residues in a
protein have such high chains so this is
an excellent way what you might consider
a fingerprint of the protein structure
and if the protein structure changes in
some way either chemically or
structurally we'll observe changes in
the NMR spectrum so what I'd like to do
is show you what kind of changes we can
induce in the protein as a test case and
now we can detect these changes by NMR
spectroscopy in monoclonal antibodies
have sugar groups attached to them
glycans and these sugar groups
strongly modulate how the antibody can
interact with an immune cell receptor so
the composition of these glycans is
incredibly important and small changes
in manufacturing conditions can change
the profile of glycans
attached to the antibody in the case of
our mist map reference monoclonal
antibody the majority of glycans sugar
groups fall into these three categories
that are shown here called G to F and
have called such because the two ends of
the glycan end in the sugar group
galactose two of them or g1 F where only
one of the two terminal has a galactose
sugar or G 0 F where there are no
galactose is at the end now as mentioned
the presence of these glycans these
sugar groups and strongly change how an
antibody binds to an immune cell
receptor and that's indicated in this
cartoon of the FC domain that doughnut
shape at the bottom being bound to an
immune cell receptor protein in green at
the top so we know that the glycans
change the nature of this binding but
interestingly when we look at x-ray
crystal structures of this complex what
we see is that the glycans don't come
into direct contact with the immune cell
receptor so the way that they change
binding with the immune cell receptor is
by slightly changing the structure and
dynamics of the parts of the monoclonal
antibody that come into contact with the
receptor so we can use the glycans as a
way to make subtle structural
modifications to the protein and detect
whether or not we can see such changes
and characterize them by NMR we have a
whole host of enzymatic processes that
we can use to modify and remodel the
glycans on our antibody we can use
enzymes that will add additional sugars
as
we see on the top left we can use
enzymes that will strip the terminal
sugars like at the bottom on the left or
we can use enzymes that will clip the
entire glycan group off completely so
these are the test cases that we're
going to look at here's a collection of
34 different animal spectra that were
measured with different parameters on
three different kinds of samples that we
made from the NIST math one sample is
the native version of the NIST map the
other is a version that's called g0f we
used an enzyme to clip off the two
galactose residues or in a third sample
we used an enzyme that trims off the
glycans completely so a deep like
oscillated sample so three samples 34
spectra have measured under different
conditions I have to say that a
difference between the nativeness map
and the g0f mica form is a matter of
changing only about three sugar groups
in a molecule with 1,400 amino acids so
it's a very minor change and it will be
interesting for us to see that we can
pick it up with NMR now when you look at
these spectra you can see that a
majority of the peaks are in a central
blob and you could imagine that that
would be very difficult to analyze by
eye and if you imagine that you'd be
exactly correct so we'd like to use some
computational methods there will assist
us in analyzing this spectrum and we're
going to use methods that will work
directly on the matrix of spectral
intensity so we'll make our analysis
based on the shapes of the spectrum
rather than any detailed interactive
analysis of individual peaks in the
spectrum and the method that we're going
to use is principal component analysis
or PCA and
in this application of PCA we will use
the spectra directly and we're going to
start by using the collection of spectra
in a multivariate or multi-dimensional
representation where each spectrum in
the series that we analyzed is
represented as a single object in a big
multi-dimensional space and the
coordinates of that object are simply
all of the intensities in the spectrum
this means we can use the spectra
directly without any need for big
analysis now what does that mean
specifically well let's say we have a 2
D spectrum that's a thousand by a
thousand points that means a million
total intensities and the intensity
matrix we can represent such a spectrum
exactly as a single object in a million
dimensional space now this seems
peculiar but if you think about this
data representation you'll see that it
has some interesting and useful
properties for example if we think about
two spectra which are more or less the
same that means their intensities are
more or less the same and that means
that they correspond to objects that lie
in more or less the same part of this
large multi-dimensional space whereas if
we have two spectra that are mostly
similar but perhaps they vary in one
place because a peak moves a little bit
from one location to another spectra
like that are going to tend to lie along
lines and curves in this large
multi-dimensional space because they're
going to have one set of coordinates in
common that is to say all the parts of
the spectra that are the same and some
small subset that vary continuously
those parts of the spectrum that are
different so this large
multi-dimensional space will group this
thing
spectra according to their degree of
similarity and difference and all we
need is a way to reduce that large
multi-dimensional space of a million
dimensions or so down to a small number
of dimensions that are reasonable for us
to visually inspect or do easier
computations on and the technique that
we use is principal component analysis
which simply fits a multi-dimensional
straight line through the data and
projects it down onto that line to
reduce the dimensionality of the
spectrum collection and so if we take
this large dimensional space and project
it down let's say to two or three
dimensions we should be able to observe
clusters and patterns that group
together the spectra according to their
similarities and differences there are
two ways that we can visualize the
results one is that each principal
component that we calculate results in a
kind of synthetic spectrum that
represents that component so one thing
we can do is visualize the component
results as spectra and the other is that
we can make scatter plots of the object
coordinates of the principal component
results so let's look at some results
for this collection of data if we
visualize the principal component
results as a spectrum the first
principal component you could think of
as a spectrum that best describes the
entire series in a least square sense so
this first component is more or less
like an average spectrum it shows us
what's in common among all the spectra
in the series and in this case we
haven't changed the protein itself all
we've done is change the glycans so
there's only a small difference in all
of those spectra in the series but now
if we subtract this and look at the
second component what we see is that
there are particular locations in the
spectra that are changing
one spectrum in the series to the other
so here's the second component here's
the third component and here's what they
look like together if we have knowledge
about the particular assignments that we
we can map this information on to the
protein and decide what parts of the
protein are being affected by the
changes that we've performed but in
addition in this case we don't happen to
have specific assignments yet but we
know do know generally which kind of
amino acids the different regions of the
spectrum represent so we can for example
tell specific changes to methionine
residues and so on but what happens when
we look at the principal component
results as a scatter plot it's very nice
what we see is we can get nice
clustering according to the sample type
so down below in blue are all the
spectra of the native miss map in the
middle are the spectra that are
associated with the g0 Africa form and
at the top spectra of that sample that
was partially deep like oscillated so
without any interactive analysis without
the need for perfectly resolved Peaks we
can go from a result which is just a
stack of spectrum through a
classification result like this now in
this case the colorization and clusters
were done manually by people who already
knew which sample was which but now we
can bring to bear the techniques of
machine learning so in this case we're
going to apply a method called
hierarchical clustering in this case
this is complete linkage analysis and in
this method each spectrum starts out in
its own cluster and at each iteration we
join together the two closest clusters
into a single group and we repeat that
procedure over and over again
till we've achieved the desired number
of clusters so here's what the result
looks like if we request the generation
of three clusters and here's the result
that we get by four clusters and use the
result that we get if we request three
clusters so this is one example of a
method where we used unsupervised
analysis of the spectrum and it can
return a useful result about the nature
of the sample there are other
interesting things that we can do in
this way for example here's principal
component analysis results of mixtures
of nativeness map with the G Z or F like
a form so we get a kind of concentration
titration curve and from this we can
estimate the fact that our detention
limit is about 10% in this case in this
example we study spectra from two
different lots of the NIST map measured
at two slightly different temperatures
and what we see here is that the
variation in spectra with respect to
temperature is much larger than the
locked a lot variation so in this case
this is a kind of proof of concept to
show how you would use this method to be
able to decide on similarity here's
another interesting aspect mostly
translational modifications like
oxidation of methionine x' can have
important clinical effects including
changing how an antibody binds to an
immune cell receptor here's an example
of three kinds of samples native one
where peroxide was added to oxidize all
of the methane aids and a third sample
which was prepared in such a way that it
performed targeted oxidation of only a
subset of all of the fine
here's what the medina region of those
three targets looks like and use what
the principal components look like so
now any interaction we were able to
differentiate these three cases of
native partially oxidized and fully
oxidized another study that we can do by
anima is to measure a degree of
molecular interaction the curve that you
see on the left hand side is an
intensity curve with respect to
increasing concentration of our
monoclonal antibody and we would expect
in an NMR spectrum that as concentration
gets higher and higher the intensity of
the peaks gets proportionally higher but
we can see somewhere between a
concentration of 40 and 60 maker Mintel
that that linear relationship changes to
a different one what this implies is at
a certain concentration there's some
kind of intermolecular interaction
that's happening that's changing the
spectrum we can characterize this by
principal component analysis so here's a
principal component analysis spectrum
the gray spectrum is the first component
the average spectrum and the blue and
red parts are the higher components we
can see that at higher concentrations
only specific parts of the spectrum are
changing so there are molecular
interactions and their specific they're
not just due to changes in the overall
viscosity of the sample they're actually
particular interactions going on and we
can differentiate for example between
changes in parts of the spectrum that
belonged to the fab domain of the
monoclonal antibody changes in the parts
of the spectrum that belonged to the NT
domain of the monoclonal antibody
and there even some signals from the
glycan that we can see change as well so
we have a mnemonic used to tell us that
a specific kind of molecular interaction
an interaction going on the principal
component analysis results when viewed
as a scatterplot also give us a kind of
calibration curves of this molecular
interaction so interestingly if we were
doing something like formulation
screening and we prepared a formulation
that we think should reduce molecular
interaction and that propensity to
aggregate we would see where such a
spectrum falls on a calibration curve
like this and decide whether or not the
excipient seems to make things better or
worse from an interaction point of view
so those are the some of the things that
we can use our principal component
analysis and Anna Marsh wore now I'm
going to turn our attention to a
recently completed study called the NIST
map international NMR at their
laboratory study this was a study but we
believe the largest of its kind
conducted by 26 organizations in nine
different companies on a variety of NMR
instruments and the organizations that
participated were nicely distributed
between pharmaceutical companies
universities and governmental
institutions and regulatory labs in this
study where we had participants from all
of these organizations each participant
was sent to different mismatched samples
and the results of the study had been
published in the journal knobs so you
can read about them at detail as
mentioned there were two different
samples one is the fab domain of the
NIST lab that was prepared by enzymatic
cleavage of the NIST Babb sample and the
other was a sample called the system
suitability sample that's a version of
the NIST map fab sequence there was
expressed
in East and originally it was intended
that these two samples would have
identical sequence but one will be
isotopically labeled but it turned out
that as a result of the particular
methods we use to express the system
suitability sample it happened to have
four additional amino acids at the end
of the two chains of the protein so it's
sequence difference in just a little bit
from the native fab and this gave us an
additional interesting source of
variation that we could test for the
spectra looked like this and of the 375
proton carbon spectra that were measured
one interesting aspect of the study was
that every spectrum was accepted and
used as input for further analysis even
in cases where there was some mistake in
the acquisition or Hardware difficulty
so some subset of these spectra are
actually very poor quality or even under
normal circumstances unusable and would
be potentially difficult to analyze by
eye but we can use these same multi
variant methods that we've seen before -
nicely classify all of these spectra
directly according to whether they are
system suitability samples are fab
samples and that works nicely we can use
these hierarchical clustering methods to
do this work and I will show you an
example so here's the hierarchical
cluster analysis being applied to the
entire collection of 375 spectra and in
this case we will stop it at five
clusters
and from these five clusters we can
completely characterize the two
different kinds of samples as a final
topic I'd like to turn our attention to
a new technique introduced by our
colleague Luke Arbogast to help study
these protein therapeutics in the
presence of exhibits this is a method
called Ciera enema it's a combination of
a special pulse sequence for measuring
data and a numerical method for treating
the data afterward now as mentioned an
important part of bio therapeutic
development is determining of
formulation which excipient should be
added and in what combination and
concentration however it's typical that
the concentration of the excipient in
these samples is often much larger than
the concentration of the protein
therapeutic itself and as a result when
we want to measure animo spectra of
samples that include excipient s-- what
we find there situations like this one
where the spectrum is dominated by large
excipient signals and these can distort
the rest of a spectrum the Sierra pulse
sequence uses a phenomenon called cross
polarization as a way to selectively
suppress signals and particular two
dimensional locations in the spectrum
without changing the rest of the
spectrum very much so this is very
beautiful and in practice it can be used
to target these specific regions and
we're going to see an example so the
regions highlighted here the four
regions highlighted in white are
excipient signals from the excipient
polysorbate the signal at the left in
yellow is the excipient history
so first we're going to use the Sierra
pulse sequence filter to try to suppress
these four polysorbate signals so this
is what they look like before the Sierra
pulse sequence is applied this is what a
spectrum looks like when the Sierra
pulse sequence is applied so we've
reduced these four signals by between 80
and 90 percent of their original
intensity and so the tails of these
signals no longer interfere with the
protein parts of the spectrum which is
what we want but when we look at the
spectrum we wondered if now that we've
experimental e reduced the size of these
signals if computationally we can do
more to suppress them and so we applied
a method called smile for spectral
modeling that's used elsewhere to
reconstruct an Tamar spectral data and
used it as a way to build a model of the
excipient signals they're leftover
excipient signals and subtract them from
the spectrum so we can generate a
spectrum clean spectrum that goes from
this where we have the small residual
excipient signals to a spectrum like
this with all the exhibit signals have
been subtracted how does it work and
here's here's the model that we've
subtracted to do the suppression the
smile technique takes a spectrum and
decomposes it as a series of individual
peaks and keeps adding Peaks to the
model until the spectrum has been
completely described
down to whatever desired residual so on
the left-hand side what you see at the
very top is what a particular region of
the spectrum in this case the histidine
excipient signal looks like and then in
the little postage stamp lots on the
right hand side you can see the
collective succession of
terms that are added to try to model
that measured histidine signal and in
the middle on the left you can see the
model as it gets larger and more
complicated to better approximate the
measured signal and then at the bottom
on the left you can see the residuals so
far so we've decomposed our signals of
interest into collections of smaller
signals and we can take them all and
subtract them from the spectrum to
generate excipient subtracted results so
in conclusion I hope you've been
convinced that 2d proton carbon NMR
spectroscopy is practical to perform at
natural abundance on molecules as large
as monoclonal antibodies and we can get
a wealth of information that's useful in
the development manufacturing of
biopharmaceuticals furthermore we've
demonstrated computational methods that
make it possible to objectively and
automatically analyze such spectra
without the need for expensive
interactive analysis and we've shown
computational methods and experimental
methods that can be combined to allow us
to study these biotherapeutics samples
exactly as they are formulated for use
so that's an overview of what we can
achieve with NMR and coupled with
methods of machine learning and
chemometrics I hope you found it
interesting thanks very much
I'm looking forward to your questions